[Music]
you'd better have a good reason for all
this rumpus hello Internet welcome to
film theory where after six years the
online video nightmare is back salad
fingers early in film series life I
tried my best to interpret the series
and all of its rust coated ink baby
filled storytelling and I think I did a
pretty darn good job after piecing
together fragmented toilet conversations
and 40s era pop culture references we
were able to diagnose salad fingers as
dissociative identity disorder his
connection to the Great War of World War
one and the series's overall themes of
childhood trauma and struggling to
belong so how does episode 11 glass
brother fit into all this after six
years of hiatus does it up end
everything that we thought we knew about
the series surprisingly no for as
bizarre as this episode is and boy does
it get weird
you gotta say it feels like the most
straightforward one that we've had to
date one that actually aligns with my
earlier analysis pretty darn well that
being said it is worth mentioning that
you might want to catch up on the
previous two-part theory right here give
them a rewatch if it's been a while and
that's not me just trying to get extra
views out of those videos I actually had
to go back and watch it myself to
remember what the heck I said because
this series is just that deep and
complex but rewarding if you're willing
to dive into all its creepy details so
now with that look back out of the way
it's time to look ahead ahead to Chapter
eleven to uncover whatever mysteries may
be held within those leafy green fingers
in episode 11 salad fingers starts off
playing with his happy finger puppet
friends just another delicious salad a
day of gnawing on him for punishment or
throwing them in the dirt salad then
chooses to focus in on Hubert cumber
tale after holding a mirror up to Hubert
and the reflection telling him that'll
never be a real boy salad takes it upon
himself to help this puppet friend grow
up a little recreating that classic
scene in Pinocchio where Geppetto so
sticky flesh chunks onto his puppet from
the dead skin collection in his junk
drawer tale as old as time this turns
Hubert into a real-life flesh boy who's
so happy salad loves this new and
improved Hubert cumbered Ale like a son
romping around their World War 1 era
wasteland well that is until salad
starts getting harassed by two people
who show up in his mirror his mother and
an evil mirror version of himself the
glass brother from the episodes title a
lot of verbal abuse and one nasty
porridge later glass brother steals
Hubert flesh boy cumbered ale spurring
salad to travel into the mirror world
and rescue him in the end salad smashes
his mirror licks up the pieces and lives
happily ever after with flesh boy see
like I said perfectly obvious what's
going on here right right okay so maybe
not in typical salad finger style even
with some kind of comprehensible
storyline there is still a lot of
weirdness to unpack in order to
understand what this episode means
rather than just simply understanding
the actions that
happening on the surface level now in my
previous theories on the franchise I
speculated that Hubert cumber Dale may
be the representation of salad fingers
himself they share the same birthday the
same weird hat Hubert has powers the
other puppets don't and they both seem
to be mistreated at the hands of their
family in short the two appear to be
linked directly to each other in a way
that salad doesn't share with other
characters in the story and this Hubert
salad connection may actually be
officially confirmed in the opening
moments of part 11 via a subtle clue
that's very easy to overlook in the
scene where salad holds up a mirror to
Hubert where we would expect to see the
puppets face reflected back at him we
instead see salads own face it's an odd
little detail especially when you
consider that David Firth the series
creator explicitly chooses to show that
the mirror adheres to real world rules
as throughout the surrounding scenes we
see the mirror accurately reflecting
other things like the freshly hair
cutted Marjorie Stewart Baxter this
feels like an intentional creative
decision to subtly allude to the fact
that Hubert and salad are indeed one in
the same or at the very least
reflections of one another
the next scene shows salad turning
Hubert into a real boy using spare flesh
now if you notice this drawer contains
memorabilia from past episodes the pub
from when salad fingers was recovering
after giving birth an episode nine
letter a bone that I actually have no
idea what it is it kind of looks like a
very small hit bone to me and the broken
nametag of Milford cubicle real name
Harry the guy in the barbecue apron who
in Episode three died banging his head
against the door and was later skin to
make salads friendship hat in episode 10
it's that reference and the fact that
he's the only character that we've ever
seen gets skinned in this series that
makes me think that this box is filled
with his spare flesh and that the flesh
being sewn onto Hubert is his let's talk
about this idea of Hubert becoming a
real boy for a second shall we
throughout the series we've seen salads
personality and well he's not your
typical man's man I mean he's not your
typical anything really but he's
definitely not what you would call
masculine we see him giving birth
wearing Brides dresses flirting with
sailors and milking himself
doing a fair bit of crying for someone
whose brother was a soldier in the great
war this sort of behavior could have
been seen as dishonorable embarrassing
especially when you consider that this
is back in the 40s salad most likely got
harassed for all these reasons so Hubert
wrapping himself up in the flesh of
someone else a male character is truly a
rebirth of sorts you can hear it in the
nursery style musical chimes in the
background the way salad heaps
compliments onto him like you would a
newborn baby the cheeks and the way
Hubert speaks reflects this too
he's a new carefree person who's just
been born and if it's a rebirth for
Hubert then we already know that it's
also representative of a rebirth for
salad fingers himself he's finally able
to give rise to something in his life
that's able to do what he always
struggled with fit in as a real boy
emphasis on boy not quite convinced
let's watch what happens next
salad immediately starts speaking about
the real boy Hubert like his own baby
specifically mentioning how lucky is to
have Hubert in his life so this is all
great salad has himself a new fleshy
baby who's also kind of a stand-in for
himself starting over but then
everything starts to go sideways when
salad encounters glass brother his
reflection in the mirror and the title
character of the episode well this is
the first place that we really notice
his appearance it's not the first time
that we've seen him remember in that
opening when Hubert looked into the
mirror and he saw salad in his
reflection well this obviously isn't a
reflection of Hubert but it's also not
really a reflection of salad either this
is the actual first appearance of glass
brother and it's immediately clear that
his defining characteristic is that he's
pretty darn nasty going on to insult
salad fingers in pretty much every way
possible
Spyder fingers you'll never be a real by
Andrew hands why is la Rosa
so mean so who or what is glass brother
is eat salads brother salads reflection
what is really going on with his
character well the answer is that he's a
little bit of both in the sense that
glass brother is the voice inside salads
head telling him that he's stupid
telling him that he'll never amount to
anything basically throughout this
episode you can think of glass brother
as being that nagging sense of
self-doubt and self-loathing that we all
have from time to time except in this
case that self-doubt is what salad sees
every time he looks at a reflective
surface
he's a reflection of salad yes but more
accurately he's a reflection of what
salad has been told is wrong with him
for his entire life young that's a
better meal by which again goes back to
the idea of salad be the boy who
struggled to fit in but through Hubert
growing up and becoming a real-life
flesh boy we see a salad fingers with
newfound confidence he's a proud parent
now which is giving him purpose and
strength you notice how in this scene
when salad first starts talking to glass
brother he immediately recognizes that
this is not himself this is not his own
reflection he tells him that he wouldn't
understand his love for baby Hubert
because yeah just a glass brother he's
dismissing that hateful voice in his own
head but as soon as he establishes that
there is indeed a difference between
them a new challenger enters the ring
the source of all that hate from the
get-go glass mother and you know that
when someone's mom symbolically shows up
in a mirror we're gonna be getting into
some deep psychological issues now we
know from previous episodes that salad
fingers had why you might call a rough
upbringing by every indication we have
from previous episodes his mother was
either abusive neglectful or bowles
she's the hateful voice speaking to him
over the radio
she's the persona whose salad switches
into when throwing Hubert into the mock
net immigrants in my house and now she's
the one reminding him your chimp and by
Yes Mother
notice that when we see salad respond
that yes he is stupid we're not actually
seeing salad respond we're seeing glass
brother respond this is an important
distinction because it gives us a big
clue as to what glass brother is the
fact that we see glass brother
responding but only see the back of
salads head further confirms that glass
brother is the version of Salad Fingers
who agrees with his mother he is the one
who does see salad as stupid as useless
as ugly again glass brother is salads
inner negative monologue reinforcing his
self-hatred and the abuse that's been
heaped on him by his family when she
asks him to fetch him in her next line
notice that salad says yes glass mother
yes glass mother this is an important
distinction because it's the real salad
talking from outside the mirror
recognizing that this is glass mother
whereas when glass brother is talking he
just refers to work as mother pass
mother that the parent because they're
on the same side all physically and
mentally from there the two of them keep
verbally abusing salad calling him a
weak little squirt and weakly bones then
interestingly the tables turn we see the
world from glass brothers side and glass
mother says yell forever just be a
loudly reflection we then hear salads
say it's not fat
I've been in here for too long these
lines give us the impression that salad
is the one trapped in the mirror world
but again this is just cluing us into
the perception that salad has of himself
he's not really in some weird alternate
dimension probably I mean the series is
weird but more likely explanation is
that salad feels trapped by all the
negative self-talk that he's constantly
experiencing from glass brother and
mother he feels like a prisoner in his
own mind in his own life and his glass
brother tells him those khaki spider
fingers aren't going anywhere except
this time it's different this time salad
has the new and improved Hubert cumber
Dale real boy aka the new reborn version
of himself to pick him up who has a new
chance at life because instead of being
put down he's now being loved and
positively reinforced by salad his
parental figure who you know is also
sort of himself you get it over the
following scenes we just get more strong
indicators that glass mothers
responsible for a lot of salad fingers
as problems including potentially
poisoning him intentionally later the
real boy comes in and takes care of him
showing the stark difference between
salads relationship with glass mother
and his relationship with the real boy
but the two of them being together
attracts the unwanted attention of glass
brother when salad talks about how
Hubert is is he's my real-life flesh by
the most beautiful boy in the lab it
inspires glass brother to steal away
salads new beginning by snatching Hubert
through the mirror where glass mother
starts straightaway to turn him into
another salad fingers the colors yet
again all of this is symbolic of salads
inability to escape his mother's
negative reinforcement and abuse and how
every attempt he's made at a new
beginning for himself is stolen away by
the faces who haunt him in the mirror
but instead of ending it on that note
honestly like you'd kind of expect an
episode of salad fingers to end we get a
big rescue scene instead haha
salad sneaks into the glass world late
at night through a puddle and I gotta
say I love this detail here he's able to
drop through the water now at night and
there
no reflection whereas earlier in the day
he did have a reflection because the Sun
was out he had to deal with himself face
to face he had to once again confront
his reflection once he's in the mirror
world he grabs Hubert and confronts
glass brother I don't think you ought to
have stolen my little flash boy this is
a huge turning point for the character
because it's clearly the first time
salad has stood up to this negative
self-talk that he's been trapped with
most of his life as soon as it happens
we see the real ugliness of glass
brother truly come out in full force
where we see his teeth turning to nails
symbolically representing how harmful
his words have been all along and then
he and glass mother start vibrating like
they're glitching out in the matrix
suddenly destabilized because salad has
upended their game he's standing up for
himself
finally the mirror shatters symbolically
breaking salad fingers out of that world
of negative self-talk salad takes action
and breaks a final mirror into tiny
pieces that are too small for any of the
characters to climb through even though
glass mother's voice multiplies because
there's now tons of mirror shards she's
powerless because salad stood up for
himself he smashes her insults up until
they're too small to hear anymore
it's really uplifting right and then
because we couldn't just have a nice
ending without some more fleshy goop
sounds salad rubs Hubert into the glass
shards in a nice way and then he licks
them off like a mama cat it's one of
those moments that feels like it's weird
just to be weird but based on this idea
that salad is breaking away from the
negative cycles of his past my
interpretation is that it's him
acknowledging that yes he is a product
of his upbringing but it doesn't have to
swallow him up instead he wipes clean
two broken shards of his past
internalizes them but remains his own
grown-up real boy and this
interpretation is reinforced by the
final shot of the episode where we see
that one small shard of glass has
survived big enough for salad to see
glass mother in still cursing the
Dickens out of him and this is actually
my favorite moment in this whole episode
because in its own bizarre salad fingers
II way it's pretty relatable salad can't
ever completely get rid of glass mother
the impact she had on and will always be
there in some small way just like we can
never a hundred percent get rid of our
own negative self-talk or the negativity
that we were seeing
from other people there's always gonna
be that one little shard left but the
cool thing about this moment is that
salad finger shows that he's okay and
yes it's definitely a little weird that
he uses the shard to cut open his finger
and smear it with blood but what this
represents is that these feelings that
glass mother will always be a part of
him and yeah she's wounded him but he
goes on to take the shard and put it
away the shard is still there it still
exists but he closed it in a box and
moved past it and now he can finally
heal and move on
a happy salad fingers ending would you
look at that
so do Hubert and salad just ride off
into their fleshy little sunset is salad
free well on one hand I'd like to say
yeah he's finally done it on the other
hand though listen to glass mother's
final line where she gets cut off
mid-sentence when she's saying wait
until your father gets home now I may
have missed it somewhere along the line
but I don't really think that we've
dealt with all of salads daddy issues
yet which seems especially relevant now
that he's got a kid of his own so in
future episodes I would expect to see a
newly confident salad fingers coming
fresh off of defeating his glass mother
now having to confront some kind of
appearance symbolic appearance corpse
appearance or finger puppet equivalent
of his father coming around so we can
finally deal with whatever he might have
in store for our little green friend am
i right about this I would genuinely
love to know if this is what David Firth
intended if so awesome it's a ton of fun
to analyze it's one of my favorite
series actually that we cover on film
theory and oh yeah I get that special
privilege of listening to all those
gooey flesh boy sounds at uncomfortably
high volumes and headphones over and
over and over again but hey if not and
I'm wrong well heck it was still fun see
you in another six years for episode 12
but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and cut
you